THEY ARE PREPARING FOR THE
INFLUX, DETAILS ARE STILL FEW
AND FAR BETWEEN.
HERE IS THE WHITE HOUSE PRESS
SECRETARY TRYING TO BLAME
REPUBLICANS.
FOR BIDENS BORDER DISASTER,
WATCH THIS.
>> WE ARE NOT ASKING FOR
POLITICAL STUNTS WE CONTINUE TO
SEE STUNTS FOR MANY REPUBLICANS
OUT THERE AND THAT'S NOT HOW WE
ARE GOING TO FIX THIS ISSUE,
THEY WANT TO SECURE THE BORDER,
WE HAVE BEEN DOING THAT WORK ON
OUR OWN AND WE ARE ASKING
THEM -- THERE'S AN IMMIGRATION
REFORM PLAN OF THE PRESIDENT PUT
OUT ON THE FIRST DAY CAN THEY
SHOULD WORK WITH US AND DO THIS
IN A BIPARTISAN WAY.
>> Tammy: WHAT DO YOU SAY TO
THAT?
LET ME BE CLEAR, THIS IS A
BORDER CRISIS CAUSED BY
JOE BIDEN, ENABLED BY JOE BIDEN,
AND WORSENING UNDER JOE BIDEN.
JOINING US NOW AS FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR, FORMER ACTING ISA
DIRECTOR TOM HOMAN ALONG WITH
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR
SARA CARTER.
YOU HEAR THAT IT'S THE ULTIMATE
GASLIGHTING, IT'S LIKE ROD
STERLING WALKING AROUND THE
CORNER AND A SECOND HE'S GOING
TO START LAUGHING AT US NONE OF
IT MAKES ANY SENSE AND WE ARE
ALREADY IN A DISASTER -- WHAT
CAN WE EXPECT ONE TITLE 42 GOES
DOWN?
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THEY ARE
PLANNING, PICNICS, WHAT DO YOU
THINK IS GOING TO HAPPEN IN A
WEEK?
>> FIRST OF ALL THE WHITE HOUSE
HOPES -- WHAT COLOR IS THE SKY
IN HER WORLD?
THIS ADMINISTRATION HAS IT OF A
SINGLE THING TO SECURE THE
BORDER AND I'M SICK AND TIRED OF
HER SAYING THEY INHERITED A
BROKEN SYSTEM -- NO, THEY
INHERITED THE MOST SECURE BORDER
IN MY CAREER WHICH SPANS 35
YEARS AND DATA PROVES THAT, I
WISH SHE WOULD STOP LYING, SHE'S
LYING IS MUCH AS SECRETARY LIES.
THEY GOT A PLAN AND THE PLAN IS
MORE NGOs WILL BE SENT TO
MEXICO TO PROCESSES PEOPLE FOR
ASYLUM BECAUSE THE NGOs
BELIEVE IT OR NOT HAVE ACCESS TO
DATABASES, LAW ENFORCEMENT
DATABASES THESE NGOs HAVE
ACCESS TO, THEY ARE MAKING
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS THEY'RE
GOING TO BE PROCESSED IN MEXICO
GIVING A PIECE OF PAPER AND
ENTER LEGALLY.
THEY WILL SAY ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION IS DOWN -- NO IT'S
NOT, GO TO A PORT OF ENTRY, IT'S
A BAIT AND SWITCH -- MARK MY
WORDS, IT'S GOING TO EXPAND
IMMENSELY AFTER TITLE 42.
>> BOTH OF YOU OBVIOUSLY HAVE
BEEN AT THE BORDER, YOU ARE DOWN
THERE ALMOST EVERY DAY, YOU ARE
RIGHT IN THE MIDDLE OF IT.
IT REALLY DOESN'T SEEM LIKE THEY
ARE GOING TO BE USING A LOT MORE
MONEY TO FACILITATE THESE
INDIVIDUALS COMING IN AND OF
COURSE IT'S THE HUMAN
TRAFFICKING WE TALK ABOUT THE
SEX TRAFFICKING WE TALK ABOUT
THE CRIME INCREASING IN THE
UNITED STATES, THERE ARE NO
PLANS TO DEAL WITH ANY OF
THAT -- ISN'T THAT WHAT WE SEE?
YOU DON'T SEE ANY KIND OF
ADJUSTMENT ON THE GROUND?
>> I DON'T AND I WILL BE
VISITING THE BORDER NEXT WEEK
AND ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
KARINE JEAN-PIERRE SAID THAT'S
SHOCKING TO ME AS SHE TALKED
ABOUT REPUBLICANS POLITICAL
STUNTS.
TODAY I POSTED BEFORE COMING ON
THE SHOW A GRAVE SITE, A
MAKESHIFT GRAVE SITE WHERE
MIGRANTS INCLUDING A BABY,
INCLUDING OTHER CHILDREN ARE
BURIED ALONG THE BORDER
COMMITTEES ARE UNMARKED GRAVE
SITES WHERE PEOPLE HAVE DIED
MAKING THEIR WAY INTO THE
COUNTRY -- THAT IS NOT A
POLITICAL STUNT.
OVER 853 PLUS MIGRANTS HAVE LOST
THEIR LIVES, THAT WAS IN THE
LAST FISCAL YEAR AND THAT'S JUST
THE ONES WE KNOW OF.
WHAT ABOUT ALL OF THE PEOPLE WHO
ARE BEING TRAFFIC -- ALL THE
CHILDREN, ALL THE WOMEN THAT WE
HAVE TALKED ABOUT ON THIS SHOW,
WE HAVE SHOWN THE PEOPLE WE HAVE
INTERVIEWED AT THE YOUNG
CHILDREN WHO HAVE TRAVELED ALL
BY THEMSELVES, WHAT ABOUT THEM?
IF THEY REALLY CARE ABOUT THE
MIGRANTS I'M GOING TO SAY IT
AGAIN -- THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION NEEDS TO SHUT
DOWN NOT TO THE NEED TO STOP
PERPETUATING THIS FINANCIAL GAME
FOR THESE NARCOTICS TRAFFICKERS
AND HUMAN TRAFFICKERS THAT WE'VE
GOT TO START FINDING A WAY TO
FIX IT BECAUSE IT'S GOING TO GET
SO MUCH WORSE AND TOM IS 100%
RIGHT.
>> Tammy: THIS IS AGAIN IN A
WEEK AT THE WORD IS ALREADY OUT,
THIS GETS TELEGRAPHED -- THEY
ARE INCENTIVIZING THIS TO
INCREASE.
IT'S ALMOST SOCIOPATHIC WHAT IS
HAPPENING HERE AND THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE HAVE GOT TO KNO